now if you live in the Southeast Valley
you may be one of the lucky residents
who did see some snow it's something
that obviously we don't get very often
here in the valley Brian will braving
the cold today at one of the snowiest s
in town
people here in Henderson woke up to
quite the winter wonderland and they got
out here about two to three inches of
snow sledding snowball fights and having
fun with their family I even spoke to
one little girl where it was her very
first snowfall we heard that it was
snowing and we were like this is our
first time in the snow Madeline Sandoval
and her daughter weren't the only ones
enjoying the snow Monday morning we also
caught up with Scott Campbell in the
middle of a snowball fight with his
daughter
that's called quick reactions do you
believe her anyway we've been out all
morning having a blast in the snow and
there's something about snow that makes
adults just feel like kids some students
even stepping out of the classroom to
see the white stuff Conor Ray came to
Mission Hills Park with his friends to
take full advantage of the snow while we
have it really really weird actually uh
this never hasn't snowed here in like
maybe two years and last time it snowed
last time I snowed was just like little
sprinkles I mean and when we asked those
in the snow for advice on how to enjoy
the weather just drive around enjoy it
while you can because it will disappear
fast and now it's here in our home and
it's awesome it's like a winter
wonderland reporting in Henderson Brian
will eight news now